[Música]
joaquín es un nombre de campo del barrio
mexicano
que tiene muchos animales
les ha tomado mucho cariño y entre ellos
se encuentra la yegua canela
a esta yegua le ha tomado un amor muy
especial porque nos lleva a ocurrir a
quienes somos un poco empáticos que
amamos a los animales pero en este
momento se encuentra muy preocupado
porque la autoridad federal de la
ganadería ha ordenado que maté a su
yegua
y se lo ha ordenado por considerar que
tiene la enfermedad que representa un
riesgo para la salud pública
el escenario pues no es muy bueno porque
normalmente hasta un árbol cuando lo van
a cuando encuentran una enfermedad lo
matan lo cortan
y con mucha naturalidad así se trata los
animales también
pero joaquín no se da por vencido y
decide acudir al juicio de amparo
corresponde esto a un tribunal
cuyo ponente interpreta la constitución
política de méxico en su artículo 1º que
se refiere
a los derechos humanos en el sentido
de que cuando el bien
recae sobre un ser vivo
no se puede ordenar su muerte
simplemente
como una medida de prevención pero
abunda en esto y dice que los derechos
humanos per se trascienden a la vida de
otros seres sin importar su especie
esto es increíble que ocurra
en un país como méxico pero está
ocurriendo y la fuerza de la sociedad
de hecho así sucedió los derechos de los
animales no son algo nuevo en méxico
desde el siglo 19
fuimos vanguardia con belisario
domínguez con benito juárez
posteriormente comenzado carranza a tal
nivel que en 1871 el código penal ya
sancionaba el maltrato a los animales y
estaban prohibidos todos los
espectáculos con animales se consideraba
que si bien el hombre podría comer o
vestirse con ellos
recordemos siglo 19 hoy existen mucho
más alternativas
no era concebible que alguien se
divirtiera con el sufrimiento y con la
muerte
tuvieron que pasar algunas décadas para
qué
se iniciará con tímidas leyes primero en
los 40s en el estado de mexico en los
80s en la ciudad de méxico y
posteriormente en otras entidades en
ciudades tímidas y parecía que
legislador quería como justificarse
decía protegemos a los animales por ser
útiles al hombre no podía entender el
legislador que merecían un respeto en
función de su valor intrínseco como
seres vivos
para mí esto inició siendo yo muy
pequeño
por qué
mi empatía fue de alguna manera natural
al ver como todos los perritos en las
calles flacos
pero algo que me marcó de una manera muy
especial todo me llevó a mi padre a ver
una vez cerrada
esto para mí un verdadero shock yo no
podía entender lo que veía en mis ojos y
desde luego
la mirada y los lamentos de ese
animalito que era incapaz de hacerle
daño a nadie
me marcó
me dejó una tarea
para hacer algo
años después de ahí el gusto de poner en
espectacular contra correos de todos los
enfrente de ese lugar
siendo estudiante de derecho lo que no
podía entender de mis maestros o de los
legisladores es que les parecía lo mismo
una piedra o una silla que un ser con
cerebro con ojos con patas con su
capacidad de acercarse y alejarse de
aquello que le agrada volver de sagrado
le da terror
se olvidaban incluso que nosotros
pertenecemos al mismo reino que todos
somos animales
y se olvidaban de los ejemplos tan
importantes que hay en otras naciones
en avances para proteger a los nuevos
manos
tenéis la trascendencia de esta nueva
visión del poder judicial de la
federación
cuando fundé a medea hace más de 21 años
la asociación mexicana por los derechos
de los animales decidí ponerle este
nombre de derechos animales para retar
al pensamiento de los colegas abogados
muchos de ellos todavía les da escozor
pensar que no seamos esta especie de
semidioses
que no estemos por encima de los demás
por el solo hecho de ser
desde luego me interesaba también hacer
una labor de equipo interdisciplinario
para poner a los profesionales al
servicio de esta causa no estar
improvisando esto es algo muy serio que
tiene que ver con ambiente y que tiene
que ver sobre todo con paz social
lo que buscamos desde luego es que estos
fueran respetados que la mentalidad
cambiará y que se trabajará con las
leyes por ellos
dentro del aprendizaje que fui
obteniendo en la media pues obviamente
estaba esta misma cuestión de hacer
equipo pero sobre todo buscando
resultados para nosotros no importaba
que lográramos una ley protectora de
animales si ésta no llegaba a alcanzar a
un animal
no podíamos festejar una ley si no
estábamos festejando que le habíamos
quitado el sufrimiento a un ser
la ley desde luego requiere también de
políticas de instrumentos que la hagan
fácil de aplicar y de adónde llevar a
los animales como rescatarlos y que
tengan un buen destino
y la tenacidad desde luego que va a ser
un arma muy importante para que no nos
dejemos caer y sigamos adelante
la resolución
y ustedes pueden ver ahí al magistrado
responsable nombre de un cargo altísimo
de una enorme sencillez y que desde
luego
pues vio con esa claridad de mente la
trascendencia de los derechos humanos a
través del principio de progresividad de
estos que lo que significa es que los
derechos humanos van tutelando más y más
a todos los seres vulnerables a todos
los discriminados y aquí estamos
hablando de una discriminación por
especie y tuvo esta nitidez para ver que
este principio permitía llegar hasta los
de diferente especie
también la constitución habla del medio
ambiente adecuado para nuestra salud y
desarrollo y eso nos permite pelear el
derecho que tenemos los empáticos y los
sensibles a no estar sufriendo de las
salvajadas que existen en la calle
abiertamente como las pamplonadas o
conocer lo que ocurre intramuros en un
rastro por ejemplo
el círculo moral se ha ampliado el
círculo moral ahora queda demostrado
también que ha permeado en las
autoridades del más alto nivel para
tener esta sentencia porque nosotros
comparamos
al asunto de la esclavitud con lo que le
ocurre a los animales no humanos desde
luego los argumentos son muy similares
se habla de que el otro el vulnerable es
que el que está a nuestra merced es un
ser sin alma sin derechos
pero en realidad lo único que están
haciendo es defendiendo su incapacidad
para ponerse en los pies del otro con
las patas son las pezuñas del otro y su
negocio desde luego la realidad de los
humanos nos lleva a imaginarnos que
sería ser un cerdo
y estar
en una caja dentro de un camión
seremos un poco los ojos y visualicemos
que nos empujan con otros cerditos hasta
que perdemos la fuerza perdemos el
aliento
ya nuestras extremidades se desvanecen y
nos estamos ahogando de nuestro propio
excremento
nos conformaríamos con una ley o con una
sonrisa de un diputado lo que queremos
es estar fuera de ahí lo mismo ocurre
con un toro cuando está en medio del
ruedo y está siendo torturado recibe
lanzas arpones
cuchillos
a él no le interesa que alguien diga por
ahí que esto es un arte
lo único que quiere es estar libre y
pisando la hierba
sin empáticos que desearíamos
lo podemos responder todos fácilmente
hay suficientes leyes en la actualidad
como para que los animales tuvieran una
muchísimo mejor vida pero no se están
aplicando no están sirviendo es
necesario hacer más leyes claro que no
lo que necesitamos es enfocarnos en la
aplicación eficaz de estas como en lo
que si vale la pena legislar es en
materia de educación tenemos que romper
muchos esquemas porque seguimos viendo a
las gallinas como fábricas de huevos oa
los cerditos como chuletas
este puede recordar que todos ellos
sienten viven tienen necesidades
que necesitamos para que las leyes se
vayan aplicando en la realidad
desde luego que cambien los perfiles de
las autoridades tiene que haber gente
que esté sana psicológicamente que sea
capaz de ponerse en el lugar de los
demás y que tenga la preparación
adecuada que conozca de derechos
animales
tenemos unas tendencias poco agradables
en lo que ha ido ocurriendo en el país
en materia de protección a los animales
esto se ha convertido mucho en la moda
vemos a personajes de la farándula
llevándose pues una fama
a legisladores también como una ganancia
política
pero deberíamos acercarnos a los
ejemplos de verdadera eficacia cuando
una sociedad en su conjunto tanto
autoridades como los propios ciudadanos
han tenido un gran éxito para defender a
los animales y el caso es
medellín-colombia de verdad los invito a
que vayan allá es envidiable ni los
europeos tienen esa protección a los
animales y lo único que ha generado es
que tengan una ciudad preciosa con mucha
paz es un cambio enorme
tengo un sueño del que voy a hablar un
poquito al final sobre la defensoría
nacional que creo que nos hace falta
como un enlace ciudadano para que las
cosas cambien y desde luego la academia
también es un ejemplo de una tendencia
que se está dando a nivel internacional
con cátedras por los derechos de los
animales refugios públicos porque la
gente tiene que estar cargando con un
trabajo de gobierno y hacerlo de manera
bien con amor hacia los animales sin
torturarlos
y como decía por la función la fusión
que se da con éxitos tanto de
instituciones públicas como privadas en
las partes del mundo es esencial
desde luego que si importa la ley desde
luego que es ésta la que regula tanto
valores universales como la moral de una
época en un lugar determinado y desde
luego la empatía la muestra la que
existe entre gobernantes y gobernados es
la que pone los límites para que los
egoístas no no pongan su razón de ser
la verdadera aplicación inhibe a la
violencia porque es ejemplar se habla de
la ejemplaridad de las penas desde luego
también tiene que haber mecanismos de
rehabilitación tanto de las víctimas
como de los victimarios de que no sirve
llevar a la cárcel a un sujeto si no
tienen tratamiento psicológico y
psiquiátrico
desde luego educar necesitamos educar
como veo al futuro
desde luego que la empatía tiene que ser
lo que nos rige nosotros hemos puesto
muchas veces barreras para protegernos
pero la verdad es que necesitamos estar
en el lugar de los demás
la forma de encontrar la paz va a ser a
través de ponernos en el lugar del otro
y tratarlo como lo dice la regla de oro
de la ética como nos gustaría ser
tratados a todos
hoy en día está institucionalizado el
que existan mataderos infames aunque hay
leyes que prohíben este maltrato pero no
hay inspectores que lo vigilen es decir
desde el gobierno
se permite esto el consumo tanto
nosotros como individuos vamos poco a
poco pensando en lo que consumimos que
esté libre de animales y no hay que
hacerlo de inmediato yo les invito a que
un día la semana no coman carne con eso
van a ayudar muchísimo
y desde luego el gobierno debería tener
incentivos fiscales para industrias o
empresas
que utilicen 0 animales en sus procesos
productivos
desde luego observó también una eficacia
jurídica tiene que combatirse la
impunidad de nada sirve que haya leyes
que no se aplicaron antes que vengan
nuevas que tampoco se apliquen
y desde luego pues que se escuche la voz
de una defensora nacional de animales
preferentemente autónoma que sea ese
organismo con profesionales que puedan
ir cambiando las políticas públicas que
establezcan los enlaces y los protocolos
necesarios para que se pueda aplicar con
toda eficacia la ley y que los animales
puedan ser rescatados
está en nuestras manos
el que dejemos de ser lo que definió a
arthur schopenhauer como el infierno en
que hemos convertido a los humanos esta
tierra para los animales seremos
nosotros mismos y nada más nosotros
quienes cambiemos esta situación gracias
[Aplausos]